welcome back so last time we related the
peak of the sensitivity function so the
maximum value of the sensitivity
function to the robustness in the
complex plane of our closed-loop system
and now that I'm looking at this I
should have probably drawn this peak I
made it look like it was a peak in the
complimentary sensitivity it should
really be a peak in the sensitivity
that's bad this is bad the peak in the
sensitivity function is bad and so the
basic idea here is that if the loop
transfer function ever gets close to
negative one ever gets close to negative
one at any frequency in the complex
plane the system is fundamentally non
robust that means if I have a little bit
of increase in gain or decrease in gain
or a little bit of a time delay or a
phase delay that rotates this a little
bit it could touch the negative one
point and blow up okay that's a cartoon
that's not exactly what's going on but
that's good enough for discussion and so
this minimum distance here M it turns
out is one over the maximum peak in the
sensitivity so if I have a maximum peak
in the sensitivity that's 10 that means
I'm only point 1 away from negative from
this instability point that means a
really close to instability so the
bigger the peak in the sensitivity
function the the minute the closer the
minimum distance of my transfer function
my loop transfer function to this
unstable negative 1 point in the complex
plane ok and we want to essentially
design our systems so that the
sensitivity function we want to have low
gain at low frequency but we also don't
want it to ever have a big peak because
that's going to mean our system is non
robust and again I'm just going to say
this again and again and again what that
what non robustness means is that if P
is a little bigger or smaller than we
think it could pass through this
negative one point and blow up if our
controller is a little bigger or smaller
or if there's a time delay so this whole
thing is rotated a little bit then the
system could blow up so that's what
non-robot
which means is that there's something
I'm not measuring or not modeling
correctly then my system could blow up
and oftentimes people will draw this as
kind of a it's a little hard to draw but
I'm going to attempt to so oftentimes
what people will do is they'll draw it
as this kind of cone of uncertainty
around the loop transfer function that
we can live with before the system goes
unstable so let me just redraw this let
me see this is my negative one point and
again let's say I'm going to draw it a
little bit closer so we need maybe it's
like that and essentially I have these
this kind of I might have some
uncertainty in my plant system so my
real transfer function might actually be
given by this kind of large band of
uncertainty okay because you know I any
model I make is just a model there's
some uncertainty there's some unmodeled
physics there's some unmodeled dynamic
maybe my constants aren't perfect and if
my model uncertainty passes through this
negative one point then there's a chance
that the system the actual system will
be unstable and I can't live with that
chance so robust control concerns things
like rocket ships going to the moon
where my model is not perfect I don't
have a perfect understanding of the
physics but I want to be able to
guarantee you that my system will remain
stable even if I have some uncertainty
so what I want is I want to move my
system as far from that negative one
point as possible so I can deal with
larger uncertainty before I might blow
up and to do that I need the peak of my
sensitivity function to be small right
the smaller the peak in my sensitivity
function the farther I am away from that
non robust that instability point and
the more model uncertainty I can live
with so things that can cause my system
to blow up our model uncertainty
and that could be essentially maybe my
systems a little bigger in gain or a
little smaller than I think it should be
and time delays okay so if I think that
my system if I'm building all of this
under the assumption that my system
responds instantaneously to my control
input and that my control input responds
instantaneously to my measurement of
Epsilon
in reality there's small time delays in
every part of this system so let's say
this is my car and I'm the controller
and I'm looking at my speedometer
there's a small time delay in how fast I
can react and so that time delay can
cause a system to go to be non robust to
blow up and so again if I have a really
really big peak in s even a small time
delay can cause my system to go unstable
so if I have time delays I need my
system to be to have a small peak in s
and be robust if I have model
uncertainty I need to have a small peak
in s to have my model be robust and
what's really interesting is that time
delays and also right half-plane zeroes
of P gave me fundamental limitations so
these give fundamental limits on how
small max s can be so this is really
interesting if I have a time delay my
system or if this system plant here has
a right half-plane zero then there's a
fundamental lower limit to how low I can
drive the peak in the sensitivity which
means I will have some fundamental lack
of robustness when I have time delays in
my system and when I right half-plane
zeroes of my system and typically the
only way that I can get around these
issues these are like hard and fast
rules that if I have time delays and
right half-plane zeroes I have to move
my bandwidth lower so I get less
performance than what I want I have to
go to lower frequency so I can only
track lower frequency reference
I can reject lower frequency
disturbances but I have to have my
sensitivity level off sooner and that
will bring my peak down closer to this
fundamental limit but if I have time to
leave and right half-plane zeros and I
try to control something really really
fast my system is going to blow up and
this makes a lot of sense if I've got a
one second time delay and I'm trying to
control something that's happening at
500 Hertz there's no way I'm going to be
able to control something at 500 Hertz
if I have a one second time delay okay
so that's just time delays and right
half-plane zeros put fundamental limits
on how high of a bandwidth you can
effectively track robustly and the right
half-plane zero I'll probably have a
video on this but for those of you who
haven't seen this before if I have a
system with a right half-plane zero
which would be something like s s minus
1 over let's say s squared that's a
transfer function with a right
half-plane zero meaning a zero of the
numerator that's in the right half plane
if I do a step response of this system
with a right half plane zero it actually
goes in the wrong direction before then
picking up and going in the right
direction now interestingly we saw this
for the inverted pendulum on a cart
problem when we wanted it to go to one
direction it actually went in the wrong
direction before it went in the right
direction so if you ever see this
behavior in your system where you step
in it and it goes in the wrong direction
before it goes in the right direction
that should tell you that there's a red
flag you have a right half-plane zero
and you will have a fundamental limit on
how high your bandwidth can be before
you lose robustness and what that means
if you think about it if this thing has
to go in the wrong direction before
going in the right direction it's almost
like this acts like a time delay this
this really acts almost very similarly
to a time delay and again if I have a 1
second delay before I can go in the
right direction there's no way I can
track something at 500 Hertz okay so
time delays and right half-plane zeros
put fundamental limitations on how high
frequency of a disturbance or reference
you can reject or track and it also puts
the fundament
limit on how far you can drive this peak
of the sensitivity down high peaks and
sensitivity are bad they make you
fundamentally non robust okay all right
thank you